[تصفيق]
بيقولوا لما الواحد بيصير عمره خمسين ما
بيكون عنده مشكله انه يصرح على عمره بيكون
عنده مشكله انه هيك صار عمره والحقيقه
بالعكس انا بعتبر انه الخمسينه هالايام
والستيني هو من الجيل المحظوظ هو الجيل
اللي عاش الانتقال ما بين اباءه الورقيين
اللي كان كل حياتو معتمده على الورق
وابناؤه الرقميين اللي هن ولدوا بين شاشات
اللابتوب والجوال والحاسد نحن جيل
الستينات والسبعينات اللي ولدنا بهداك
الفتره ويمكن بدايه الثمانينات نحن كلنا
ورقيين ورقميين بان واحد تعلمنا هون
وتعلمنا هون ودخلنا هذا العالم الجديد
اللي هو له طابع سحري
فهذاك الايام قمه التطور والقفزه المعرفيه
بحياتي صارت لما تلفزيون للفليكس الابيض
والاسود انتقل وصار تلفزيون سيرونكس ملون
الحياه كان هذا الشيء مدهش بالنسبه لالنا
قلنا نشوف المذيع ونشوف البيئه كلها ملونه
بهذيك الايام نحن دخلنا وبدينا نتعلم
اختصاص الهندسه المعلوماتيه اختصاص اختصاص
بالعالم الرقمي عالم رقمي تجسد بهداك
الوقت
بصاله كبيره مليانه شاشات مليانه لوحات
مفاتيح وكلن موصولين على شي اسمه حاسب
مركزي شغله هيك عملاقه بالنص بنص الغرفه
او بغرفه ثانيه كلها بكرات وادراج حقيقه
في تعطي هيبه بتعطي رعب احيانا لهاللي عم
يتعامل معه بهذيك الايام كان باختصاصنا
لنتعلم البرمجه لازم نكتب اسطر طويله
وطويله من الكود باحرف خضراء على الشاشه
سوداء واستر طويله لنحل معادله رياضيه او
معادله منطقيه وهديك الايام كمان وقت كنا
بدنا ننفذ هالبرنامج اللي كتبناه ونشوف شو
نتيجه البرنامج اللي عملناه كان لازم نرمي
وننتظر ست او سبع دقايق لحتى هذا الحاسب
يعطينا النتيجه وطبعا الغلطه كانت بكثره
لانه اذا كنت غلطان وبدك ترجع تبرمج وتصلح
وترجع تطلب من الحاسب انه ينفز لك الشغل
تبعك كنت لازم ترجع تنتظر ست او سبع دقايق
تاني يوم انت تعلمنا الصبر ومع الصبر
تعلمنا التدخين لحتى نحرق سيجاره بدل ما
نحرق اعصابنا
حيه كل هذا بنقدر نلخصه بكلمتين نحن كل
هالقفزات المعرفيه اللي عشناها انتقلنا من
هالصاله الكبيره بحاسبها الكبير بشاشاتها
بلوحات المفاتيح وجت بعدها مايكروسوفت
وابل اخترعت لنا الحاسب الشخصي ام رح كل
واحد منا اخذ حاسبه وانتقل قعد بغرفته
لوحده وصار يشتغل عليه بعدين ظهرت
الانترنت بالتسعينات بالتسعينات لما ظهرت
الانترنت وعشنا هالنقله اللي صار فينا انه
شبكنا كل هالحواسب مع بعض وبدل ما كنا
قاعدين عم نتعامل مع حاسب واحد بصاله
مركزي صرنا عم نتعامل مع حاسب موجود بمكان
ما بالعالم هو عملاق وبدايه الالفيه لما
تم اختراع الويب الويب واحد والويب اثنين
والويب ثلاثه مصطلحات التكنولوجيه اليوم
رجعنا نعيش مع بعض بقاعه واحده نشتغل اون
لاين نتعامل اون لاين نتعلم اونلاين
كلياتنا مشبوكين حتى اليوم نحن قاعدين
بقاعه واحده ومساحتها العالم كله عم نحكي
مع بعض وين ما كنا بالعالم حقيقه رجعنا
نفس الموديل اللي بدينا فيه ولكن على
مساحه هي العالم وما هيك رغم كل عظمه
التكنولوجيا ورغم كل شي صار وكل التطور
اللي حاصل واللي حكيت لكم عنه من هديك
الايام هاي من كاميرا البولورويت
والتلفزيون الابيض والاسود لعالم
الميتافيرس وفيسبوك وانستجرام وغيره نحن
براي كتير ناس فقدنا على قد ما ربحنا
فادنا اولا الحس الجماعي والحياه الجماعيه
مع بعض اليوم حياتنا كلياتها مربوطه برني
بتظهر على الجوال لاحظتوا شو قالت الصبيه
قالت لكم رجع ضعوا جوالاتكم على الصامت هي
ما استرجعت تقول لكم الرجاء اطفئوا
جوالاتكم لانه هي راح تعرف ان واحد راح
يرد عليها وما حدا راح يطفي جواله والكل
بده يطلع كل خمس دقائق على هذا الجوال
حقيقه هذا اللي صار نحن هلا حاليا بنكون
قاعدين كلنا مع بعض بتيجي رنه عيوننا
كلياتها بتتعلق بالجوال المفارقه اليوم
انه اي واحد مو موجود معك هو اهم من اي
واحد موجود معك فقط لانه هو بعث لك على
هذا الجوال
فانا العمق
وفادنا التركيز فادنى الصبر فادنى كان احد
اساستي اللي يا ابني لحتى تتعلم لازم
تعاني طبعا تعاني معاناه دراما
التلفزيونيه ولكن المعاناه اللي تعني انك
انت تقعد تقرا اسطر واستروا صفحات وصفحات
من الحبر الاسود المكتوبه على صفحه بيضاء
لحتى تقدر توصل لمعلومه بدور بعشرات
واحيانا مئات الكتب وتربط المعلومات
ببعضها لحتى تقدر توصل لمعلومه وتربطها
بمعلومه تانيه
المعاناه اللي والقراءه والشرف اللي كان
ممكن تخليك تشتري سندويشه فلافل مربوطه
بورق جرايد ولما تاكلها تقرا ورقه تجاريه
اللي كانت ملفوفه فيها السندويشه كل هذا
نحن خسرناه خسرناه وهذا كله خساره للعمق
المعرفي اليوم عنا مشكله هائله وهي بسموها
وهم المعرفه حجم المعلومات اللي نحن عم
نحصل يوميا عم تخلينا نعتقد انه نحن عنا
معرفه انا شخصيا فات اشخاص بعرفهم لانه
كان عندهم وهم المعرفه توفوا وقت ازمه
الكورونا لانه هن اعتقدوا انه هن ممكن
يطبوا حالهم من المعلومات اللي عم ياخدوها
على النت او من المعلومات اللي ممكن
ياخذوها من السوشيال ميديا ولما اكتشف انه
هو راح يخسر خسر حياته لما هو ما قدر
يراجع طبيب او يراجع صيدلي واعتبر انه هو
قدران يكون عنده معرفه اكثر من طبيب او
اكثر من هذا كلياته نحنا خسرناه خسرنا هذا
العمق المعرفي وصار عنا وهم المعرفه بس مع
هيك
شو الحل حقيقه الحل هو بايد الجيل اللي
كان جيل ورقي ورقمي حاليا او جزء كبير من
الحل بايد هذا الجيل حقيقه نحن جيل اللي
متل ما قلت هاجر من عالم الى عالم بس مثل
اي مهاجر يوم ما بتهاجر انت بتحمل ثقافتك
وهي الثقافه ممكن تكون غنى للثقافه
الجديده بالنهايه كل المهاجرين اللي راحوا
من عنا وراحوا للغرب يمكن نقلوا ثقافات
والحقيقه خلقت ثقافات غنيه يوم ما دخلنا
على الموسيقى الشرقيه نغمات غربيه حياتنا
خلقت اغاني خالده وممكن تكون مستمره
وتستمر لاجيال ونفس الشيء يوم ما انت
بتنتقل من ثقافه لثقافه اهم شيء انك انت
تنقل هذه الثقافه وتحاول توصلها للجيل
اللي بعدها كيف يعني اول شيء خلينا نعترف
انه التغيير صار لانه في جزء كبير من
جيلنا لساته عم يعارض هذا التغيير وعم
يعتبر انه هو ما صار وانه هذا الشيء
الجديد
صار
ولنقتنع انه هذا التغيير صار واذا بدنا
نساعد بهذا التغيير لازم نفهم هالادوات مو
بس نستخدمها للتسليه نفهمها لنعرف نحكي مع
الجيل الجديد او الجيل القادم بنفس اللغه
نعرف نعلمه بنفس لغته نعرف ننقله المعرفه
بنفس لغته هاي وحده من المشاكل اللي نحن
حاليا عم نعاني منها النقطه الثانيه
المهمه كتير هي انه ننقل له فكره العمق
المعرفي نفرجيه قديش التكنولوجيا عظيمه
قديش قادره على انه تعطيه هالكميه
المعلومات لهائمه ولكن قديش مهم انا اعرف
حاكم المعلومه انا اعرف اتاكد انه هاي
المعلومه صحيحه انا اعرف اربط هاي
المعلومه بمعلومه ثانيه موجوده لحتى اخرق
الشيء اسم المعرفه والاهم ايضا نخلي هذا
الجيل يتعلم الصبر يتعلم شيء اسمه مسار
مهني وتراكم مهني اليوم
من اسهل ما يمكن حصول شب على عمل وخصوصا
عمل اونلاين
وفريلان ولكن من السهوله بمكان انه هو
يغير شغله نفس المؤسسات اللي هي كتير دعمك
ودفشت باتجاه دوران العماله وباتجاه بانه
تتغير بسرعه اليوم عم تكتشف انه هي ارتكبت
خطا كبيره لانه هاي المؤسسات اكتشفت انه
بالسرعه اللي هو العامل تبعها بيتركها
فيها زبونه رح يتركها فيها لانه هي تحولت
لمؤسسات بلا هويه بعمال بلا هويه بزبائن
بلا هويه حقيقه هذا كله جاي من فكره اليوم
انه اي شب بتشوفه بيبدا بشغله بعد شهر
زمان بقول لك انا مو ملاقي حالي بهذا
الشغل انا بدي غيره انا مو عاجبني هذا
الشغل حقيقه هاي المشكله ومشكله كبيره
بالنسبه له مشكل بالنسبه لمؤسسه اللي عم
بشتغل فيها مشكله كل المجتمع حتى الاحساس
الدائم بانه نحن بدنا نغير وحيه بدون ما
يكون عنا تجربه قويه
نلخص كل شي ونقول
الصبر
المعاناه التعلم الفهم الخبره
التعاطف العطف الحب الكره هي لازم توصل
لهجيل الجديد ويفهم انه هي عباره عن امور
بتاخد وقت بتاخد زمن تحتاج
لنجاح وفشل ومرور بمراحل كثيره هاي لا
يمكن تتم لا بضغط الزر ولا بدقه لايك ولا
بعمليه شير ولا بعمليه بلوك عم يساويها
على السوشيال ميديا حياه هاي امور تاخذ
زمن وبتاخذ وقت هاي الامور بتشكل التجربه
التجربه اللي بنسميها تجربه الانسانيه وهي
اهم فكره لازم نوصل له اياها شكرا
[تصفيق]